you know writing letters uh to yourself
by the way is such a clever idea and i
know it's a conceit for the story
line but
writing yeah is such a powerful thing
for sure for me it's i songwriting is
how i get all of my you know feelings
that i'm having difficulty processing or
experiences that i don't quite
understand
out it's a really cathartic kind of
outlet to have to just express things
similarly to theater and that you can't
express
by chatting and your new album that i'm
so excited about
i mean
now you wrote this quarantined in your
bedroom
which sounds almost like childhood
rather than like this is your adult
you know dream album what was it like
writing this album in your childhood
bedroom um being in my i moved home for
the pandemic to live with my with my
parents and
staying in my childhood bedroom and
seeing all of my like theater posters on
the wall and my old clothes and stuff i
felt this really weird like
uh limbo where i was like caught between
all this nostalgia and like my teen self
and who i used to be and what i used to
care about and then all of a sudden
feeling like a little more evolved and
adult-ish and you know in a new
relationship and just feeling so
different from that now and i think like
being caught between those two worlds in
that bedroom is like ended up being a
really inspiring place to write and
that's kind of where the whole album
came from so i wrote a lot of it over
zoom with my co-writers on my little
keyboard that's still in my bedroom and
um and then it came out um
so you quarantined in l.a and now you're
back in new york
ish i'm kind of all over the place
because of the film and promoting and
stuff and traveling again yes and my
boyfriend works on the show called the
good doctor so he shoots in vancouver so
i'm trying to be close to the west
whenever i can but new york is where my
heart is and where i want to be so i'm
i'm hoping to be here
i have a quick uh rapid fire questions
for you about new york if you will it's
called new york minute
[Applause]
i like that they have the horns in there
okay start it now favorite date spot oh
uh uh abc cocina really yummy oh yes
okay best new york bagel oh god um
uh
a bodega bagel okay best spot for people
watching oh um maybe prospect park is
fun
favorite view of the city oh for my
apartment window
best place to cry
my bad
best new york pizza francesco's on the
upper west side oh hitting that today
best coffee
um
starbucks
good best subway line best subway the
one i use the one the most uh where's
subway line
um
i they're all fine okay perfect i guess
that's good
favorite new york movie
oh
oh
that's so hard i know oh well this is
called new york minute so new york
minute bash is american ashley movie
that is so fun uh one place you wanted
to go but never have had the chance
um i
oh coney island i've never been to coney
island no way really okay
[Applause]
can i go to coney island with you yeah
seriously yeah let's go okay and before
you go we wanted to do a little
something to celebrate your birthday so
we got you these
oh yeah
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
nick and uh and
they play best friends in the movie and
dear evan hansen and so
um who better to call on than your real
life and cinematic best friend
oh my
god you gotta look at them
so cute how great is that they're so
cute
um and i'm wondering if we could go out
on unhappy birthday to ben song
[Applause]
happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear ben
happy birthday to you
thank you
[Applause]
is in theaters now
but today everyone in the audience is
going home with a copy of the soundtrack
thank you nick to johnny for showing
yeah thank you for having
[Applause]
we get to me
[Music]